nowadays animated disney movies are a
surefire recipe for box office success
unfortunately in the past even disney
has put out a few commercial duds
here's the real reason why these
animated disney movies bombed at the box
office
fantasia was the passion project of walt
disney himself
in fact he was so in awe of the 1940
musical that he once said
fantasia is timeless it may run 10 20 or
30 years
it may run after i'm gone fantasia is an
idea in itself
i can never build another fantasia i can
improve i can elaborate
that's all sadly walt's passion failed
to translate into initial massive box
office returns the film's first
screenings at a roadshow engagement
didn't turn a profit thanks to the
expensive costs of setting up the sound
system known as
fantasound which was intended for use in
theaters showing fantasia
those costs meant that fantasia was
always going to struggle to turn a
profit
on top of that the avant-garde nature of
the feature initially turned off general
moviegoers and
even some critics in the end fantasia
lost disney the modern equivalent of
more than 15 million dollars and nearly
drove the company into bankruptcy
while fantasia initially proved to be
too costly and unusual to be successful
right away the film would find itself
profitable decades later
a 1969 theatrical re-release saw
fantasia finally turning a profit while
a subsequent re-release in 1990 took in
25 million dollars so despite bombing in
its first theatrical run fantasia did
indeed live up to walt disney's hopes of
running long after he was gone
today sleeping beauty is seen as one of
the jewels in disney's crown
but during its initial 1959 release the
movie was nothing more than an outright
box office dud
the film cost six million dollars to
produce and brought in a little more
than five million dollars thanks to
sleeping beauty walt disney productions
lost money between 1959 and 1960 for the
first time
in a decade popular explanations for the
project's struggles to initially connect
with viewers are its distinct animation
style as well as a negative reception to
the scariness of the movie's villain
maleficent
it's also hard to imagine any film in
1959 making much money with a budget as
high as 6 million dollars
for example the second highest grossing
film of 1959 was the shaggy dog with the
9.6 million dollar domestic haul which
clearly demonstrates that any 1959 film
would struggle to turn a profit when it
cost as much as sleeping beauty
this box office performance lent an
initial negative tinge to sleeping
beauty's reputation but
it wouldn't be there for long further
theatrical re-releases in 1979
and 1986 helped to restore the film's
box office reputation
and the latter re-released managed to
gross an impressive 15 million dollars
domestically
the black cauldron was supposed to kick
off a whole new era of animated disney
filmmaking
channeling the darker tone of 1980s
fantasy movies rather than more classic
disney fair the movie was a departure
from the norm of what animated disney
movies could be
in execution however the black cauldron
ended up being a box office disaster for
the studio
grossing just 21 million dollars
domestically on a 44 million dollar
budget the black cauldron's box office
was so
meager that it was outgrossed by the
care bears movie
in 2010 slate would dub the black
cauldron the movie that almost killed
disney animation
among the chief reasons the film failed
to connect with audiences was that early
reviews made a point of emphasizing just
how dark and scary it was
this ensured that the project turned
away its primary demographic
kids and their parents the black
cauldron also suffered financially
because it was greenlit by disney
executives who were gone by the time the
repeatedly delayed project was released
with the new executive team being
nowhere near as invested in the movie's
production
the first sequel in the walt disney
animation studios canon the rescuers
down under took the lead characters of
the rescuers to the australian outback
giving the rescuers an adventure in
australia was meant to capture the box
office power of then recent australian
hits such as crocodile dundee
unfortunately the rescuers down under
didn't have a good day
at the box office with a measly 27.9
million
domestic haul part of the problem down
under faced was that by the time it came
out in november 1990
american audience's fascination with
australia was waning
it had already been two years since
crocodile dundee ii came out and even
that made less than its predecessor
it had also been 13 years since the
original rescuers premiered so fans
weren't exactly clamoring for a sequel
by that point
a bigger problem for rescuers down under
however was that it had to face off
against the family movie juggernaut home
alone in its opening weekend
that live action features sword
financially taking in 285 million
dollars over its domestic gross
rescuers down under couldn't even hit 10
of that gross in its domestic run
after a dismal opening weekend disney
animation had jeffrey katzenberg ordered
all rescuers down under marketing to be
pulled
this of course ensured that the movie
couldn't develop legs in the long
run and pretty much killed its chances
at the box office
during the early 1990s walt disney
animation studios was
nigh on unstoppable beauty and the beast
aladdin
and the lion king were all gigantic hits
each one bigger than the last
but the hot streak started to fizzle
after the lion king with pocahontas
making noticeably less than the previous
two disney animation efforts
this problem had worsened by 1997 when
hercules prominently signaled that
disney had
lost some of its box office strength
grossing 97 million
domestically hercules became the first
disney animation title to gross
under 100 million dollars domestically
since the rescuers down under in 1990
just three weeks after the film's
initial release disney was claiming that
increased competition from fellow summer
1997 blockbusters like men in black was
to blame for the movies under
performance
however an unnamed disney insider told
the new york times that hercules box
office woes could be attributed more to
the fact that it only appealed to young
children rather than audiences of all
ages
worse still hercules has never really
worked as a brand name in hollywood with
more modern releases such as the legend
of hercules and brett ratner's hercules
also struggling to make money at the box
office
sadly it seems like hercules just never
stood a chance
nearly 60 years after its initial
release fantasia received a sequel in
the form of fantasia 2000.
after a limited concert release fantasia
2000 debuted
exclusively in imax on january 1st 2000.
it was followed by a more traditional
release that summer
over its opening weekend fantasia 2000
took in 2.2 million dollars from just
54 theaters unfortunately that excellent
box office wouldn't be replicated when
it was given a wider release six months
later
fantasia 2000 eventually grossed 60.8
million
domestically on an 80 million dollar
budget the fractured release method of
fantasia 2000 doubtlessly hurt the
movie's chances at the box office
although it was meant to be an event you
had to see in a theater fantasia 2000
couldn't keep up its event status in the
six month period between its imax debut
and its general release
put simply what was a classy must-see in
december 1999 had become old news by
june 2000
there's also the fact that fantasia has
always been a fairly niche disney
property
it's not exactly by the numbers
children's entertainment and that meant
fantasia 2000 was always going to
struggle to compete against
more conventional family-friendly fair
released in the summer of 2000 like
disney's own dinosaur
during production crew members working
on atlantis the lost empire wore
t-shirts that carried the phrase
fewer songs more explosions this piece
of crew merch perfectly embodied how
atlantis was planned as a radical
departure from the usual disney fair
indeed atlantis was a straight-up action
slash
adventure film with set pieces taken
right out of a ray harry hausen film
while its character designs evoked the
art of mike mignola more than the
traditional visuals of other disney
movies
all these unique qualities however
couldn't quite help atlanta stand out at
the box office
grossing just 84 million dollars
domestically on a 90 million dollar
budget atlantis became only the second
post
1990 animated disney movie to be
released in the summer time and gross
under 100 million dollars domestically
more than anything
atlantis failure can be traced back to
another family-friendly cartoon from the
summer of 2001.
layers onions have layers
yes the runaway success of dreamworks
shrek combined with middling reviews for
atlantis
meant that disney's hopes of winning the
2001 summer box office battle were
ogre before they began disney animation
had endured its fair share of box office
duds long before treasure planet sailed
into theaters
but none were ever quite as fatal as
this
released in november 2002 treasure
planet opened to a dismal
12.1 million dollars and grossed just
91.8 million dollars worldwide on its
massive 140 million dollar budget
the film was widely seen as a herald for
the demise of hand-drawn animation
while its box office performance proved
so momentously awful that the los
angeles times later declared it one of
the costliest box office flops in
history
ever since the release of oliver and
company in 1988 animated disney movies
had frequently reigned supreme over the
thanksgiving holiday
so why was treasure planet such a
massive bomb
screenwriter terry rozio who wrote
treasure planet story
opined that turning treasure island
protagonist jim hawkins into a teenager
for treasure planet alienated audiences
meanwhile november 2002 was packed with
family films including the santa claus 2
and
harry potter and the chamber of secrets
meaning the competition was even tougher
than usual
another pressing issue was that treasure
planet was coming hot off
a series of action-packed hand-drawn
animated movies that had also flopped
like titan ae and of course atlantis the
lost empire
put all that together you're on a course
for a genuine
disaster at the time of its release
2004's home on the range was a truly
historic movie
this animated western was intended to be
the last disney feature produced in
hand-drawn animation and every movie
from that point onward would use
computer animation instead
sadly home on the range didn't send out
disney's era of hand-drawn animation in
a blaze of glory as the movie grossed
just 50 million dollars domestically
home on the range's release was plagued
with a number of issues including the
fact that it came out in early april
the biggest disney animation titles had
always been released in either
summertime or at thanksgiving
then there's the fact that home on the
range faced competition from another
family movie
scooby-doo 2 monsters unleashed those
problems could have been overcome if
home on the range had generated positive
reviews but the film received mixed
marks from critics with a 53
rotten tomatoes critics rating a far cry
from the acclaim that had greeted the
disney movies of the previous decade
without any positive buzz to buoy it
home on the range
became yet another casualty of the dark
days of disney animation
since 2005 every single feature from
walt disney animation studios has made
at least 97 million dollars domestically
the lone exception to that rule however
is the 2011 feature
winnie the pooh which made just 26.6
million dollars
whose box office woes could be
attributed in part to what can
only be described as poo fatigue
[Music]
between 2000 and 2005 a trio of poo
movies hit the big screen each making
less than its predecessor
even with winnie the pooh being the
first to be made by walt disney
animation studios in nearly 35 years
moviegoers just weren't interested in
seeing more of a.a milne's silly old
bear on the big screen
then again perhaps moviegoers would have
been keener on winnie the pooh if it had
received a more favorable release date
the movie was released domestically on
july 15 2011
putting it smack dab in between a number
of huge kids movies
three weeks prior disney's own cars 2
debuted while 2 weeks later the smurfs
would hit theaters
worse yet pooh opened against harry
potter and the deathly hallows part 2
which scored the biggest opening weekend
in history at the time
the saddest thing of all is that winnie
the pooh actually received some of the
best
reviews of any major movie released in
summer 2011.
facing off against wizards cars and
smurfs however
portal pooh bear just didn't stand a
chance check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one